we begin in the middle east where a
fragile truce between hamas and israel
is in place
after more than a week of deadly
fighting let's get right to mts tayyip
in jerusalem
in tiaz tensions are still dangerously
high is the ceasefire holding
vlad good morning well this cease-fire
is holding
very fragile but we have seen here in
east jerusalem major tension behind me
at the al-aqsa mosque where israeli
forces and palestinian protesters
were confronting each other all of that
very concerning
but for now there have been no israeli
airstrikes
or hamas rockets
on the bombed out streets of gaza a
mixture of joy
and relief after 11 horrifying days of
fighting
ended in a truce between israel and
hamas
hamas is claiming victory but after more
than 230 palestinians were killed
and vast devastation it's a hollow one
in an address to the nation about the
ceasefire israeli prime minister
benjamin netanyahu said
we operated together to protect our
people twelve israelis
were killed in the fighting tal
schneider is an israeli political
analyst
there's a ceasefire if it holds
is there a winner i think all sides are
losing i don't see anyone here who is
winning
those conflicts it is repeating sin
conflict after conflict and all sides
are losing
overnight in east jerusalem where this
all began
fireworks lit up the night sky but this
morning
a sense the long festering issues still
haven't been resolved
do you really don't believe that
anything's going i don't believe it is
so but hamas claims it received
assurances israel will not
enter the al-aqsa mosque again and that
the looming expulsions of palestinian
families from east jerusalem by jewish
settlers won't happen
but israel's defense minister calls
those claims completely false
now the world has hailed this truce but
we have to be very cautious here
back in 2014 in the last gaza war a
conflict i covered extensively
there were nine truces all of them fell
apart
and the concern now is that this latest
truce could also
fall apart anthony all right mts tayyip
in east jerusalem thank you